my name tag secure says for signing
books afterwards pardon my silence I
can't speak hello pharyngitis so can you
hear me or not okay no all right let's
let's try the rest of kenya let's be
right into it you know I I don't can you
hear me now can you hear me in the back
okay well I'm just as well that on you
listen closely because I'm going to tell
you some secrets at the beginning trade
secrets here but we're all in the
business here a year all of them
business right I've never spoken to
booksellers before last week and of
course I got laryngitis before my book
tour started so we'll see what happens
but actually being in this house chamber
though it's only a house I want to ask
your advice as booksellers about the
title of my book of course whatever you
say it won't change the title it's not a
little like a president last week
consulting with Congress but I want to
consult with you I've been Ivan's na UN
next week I've been watching him closely
how he operates so I'll tell you how he
came to the title secrets here actually
this was the working title for the book
from the time I first proposed it to
like is there a Viking representative
here by the way good okay don't let this
get beyond this room Europe some behind
the scenes here a little bit that's what
I do it was the working title up through
the point when I sent the manuscript and
all finished notes interviewing a couple
of months ago and my editor said
everyone here loves it marketing people
love it they're very excited by this
book
by the way it has a new title this was
days before was to go into the catalog
which was the moment of truth here on
the title she said it's now called
keeping secrets I said boom actually
said the marketing people are really
like that they were excited by it I said
Tom who came up with that she said the
vice president she runs in the
corporation yet another analogy to her
mation situation here yet so she said
now she she liked it at keeping secrets
i said but that's not what i did i said
said don't worry about that it'll sell
well I said well it's the opposite of
what I did did she really read this book
what did quick could she possibly have
had in mind she's well she wanted two
words and one of them had to be a verb
so I thought about it for a while and I
said I can't live with this we've got to
find two other words so she said ok how
about telling secrets said well that's
what I did I wasn't crazy about it but
when I went home and told my wife and
her friends why females reacted this way
they said impossible as Sam Goldwyn used
to say in two words impossible they said
a tattle-tale telling tales out of
school which is sort of what I do wrong
to unseat sounds trivial sounds like God
cannot cannot do so I came up with
title unauthorized disclosure that may
not be too familiar to you but that's
the official term for leaking I've never
really liked the term leaking my wife
hates hates me to be called a leaker
says it sounds incontinent so but anyway
unauthorized disclosure has been in the
news a lot because nearly every other
day Secretary of Defense Donald Rumsfeld
is talking about unauthorized
disclosures which are ruining our
national security and which are
definitely crimes and for which people
will go to prison when he prosecutes
them which he will do as soon as he
finds out who possibly could have done
this and they've been there are many
many more unauthorized disclosures than
there were during the Vietnam War at
this stage or even later and I think by
the way I disagree with Rumsfeld I think
that's all to the good for the first
talkin Gulf Resolution which was passed
the week I went to work for the Pentagon
in August of 1964 there were two
senators who voted against it not 23
there was a zero House of
Representatives zero voted against that
that bill at that time so this is
definitely improvement and it would not
have been 133 members many Republicans
and Democrats no no many Democrats in
the house several Republicans we hit
that streak several Republicans in the
House gym leagues and others one
Republican in the Senate Chafee of Rhode
Island in many Democrats who voted in
the minority of Democrats even against
this bill this time that would not have
happened without the unauthorized
disclosures that people have honorably
been giving patriotically been giving
allowing a degree of debate far far
but very inadequate but far greater than
happened the week I came to the Pentagon
in August of 64 so there were some votes
actually somebody had picked up the form
in the Pentagon and called senator
Morris before he was through Christian
secretary defence McNamara in hearings
top secret hearings on August fifth i
believe was the day after i came i
regret to say and warned him what
questions to ask to say raise these
questions i can't tell you anymore he
didn't give him any documents and with
that the Moores did raise the questions
he was not able to do anything about the
flat explicit top secret lies he got
from Secretary of Defense McNamara an
answer they go through this in the book
what the lies were what I know as a
lowly I was a high-paid I was a high
level c civil servant at that point I
came into the government but I was
looking as a high-paid clerk an
assistant to an assistant secretary of
defense no decision-making role whatever
but I handle a lot of paper and I saw
the paper that was coming over my desk
on August fourth was the day my first
day of the Pentagon took 24 hours I
spent all night there because i was
watching the raids our first air attacks
over vietnam which started that night
that morning in the Tonkin Gulf in
response to what was alleged to be a an
attack on our ships then [ __ ] up back
to that in a minute actually that's the
that's the story that starts this book
action I didn't know this book would be
coming out the week the Tonkin Gulf to
was
and timely I'm unhappy very unhappy for
my country that this book is so timely
anyway let me finish up come back to
that how much time do we have doing okay
i don't know if i don't okay i don't
know if my voice is up to that answer
anyway coming back to the title we're
working with unauthorized disclosure
which as you can see i'm for so i liked
giving the book unauthorized disclosures
the title i want to stick it in Donald
Rumsfeld's I to be to be truthful and
say here it is there's more of them
clearer and more come and come and get
me and we'll see what the prosecution
picture is because he's bluffing to a
considerable degree he doesn't have a
law to go with it would clearly stand up
as constitutional if it went to the
Supreme Court of course the supreme
court until worries them but we don't
have an official secrets act congress
for the first time passed an official
secrets act for the first time in our
history three years ago in the last days
of clinton's rule to any of you
booksellers know that that happened is
there somebody let me see a hand so you
don't know that clinton vetoed that
which is why we don't have an original
act at the moment this president would
not veto that when it comes up again
needless to say and that was true before
nine eleven that'll make a difference my
book i think is sort of addressed
without knowing it would come out this
year to the question of why we should
not have an official secrets act why we
do not because of the First Amendment
and why the founders of our country the
drafters of the First Amendment happen
to be James Madison had it right at the
time and this is not the time to remove
that amendment or get an official secret
set so anyway said okay unauthorized
disclosure two words she said
sounds like a spy novel I said well
alright figure out what's wrote it up so
she said now it sounds like something by
tom clancy he said hmm well here's a
title for you unauthorized disclosure by
tom clancy you don't even have to put my
name on the cover at all of modest she
said the legal department wouldn't buy
it anyway we came up with we came back
to the title sequence so how many of you
would have preferred keeping secrets
you're the seller's telling secrets see
one hand for telling secrets best title
this is not a very responsive you're
looking like the Republicans in Connor
no I in Congress Eric and you're
supposed to put your hand up when I I'm
not the president I go
told you this that was insider stuff I
was telling how titles are regular as an
old story that two things you never want
to see made sausage and legislation and
this is my book is about the process of
decision making ok so then Pentagon
Papers how many of you be frank on this
one then but whether you're book sellers
or not need to know what the Pentagon
Papers were or what that was about how
many of you you can't hear me let me see
hands don't be modest on this because I
won't take the time otherwise what do I
need to tell you a little about what the
Pentagon Papers for you say no but a few
people say I'll say it very briefly it
was a study that I worked on in the
Pentagon what I came back from Vietnam
in fact again since thank you i got a
brief good but brief introduction i
don't know how many of you know my
background which goes in this how many
need a few words on on white background
okay right if we only had brief time I
wouldn't do it he mentioned I was a
Harvard ph.d that was after I got out of
the US Marine Corps which I enlisted in
as an officer Kennedy during the Korean
emergency in 54 fighting was mostly over
then but that was because I gotten
deferred for two years now to go to
Cambridge University in England finish
my BA and wondering and I felt being a
strong cold warrior already at that time
and really throughout the period of this
book which goes up to 73 very patriotic
I was 14 when the war ended the second
world war grew up on war movies on John
Wayne John
specifically and enlisted recruited me
into the Marine Corps with the sands of
Iwo Jima I don't know how many people
are old enough to remember that one and
that recruited most of the Marine Corps
and reap in reruns I met him once when I
was in the Marines and bought him a
bottle of wine we were at a restaurant
together and I went in the Marines the
feeling that I'd been deferred had a
deferment and it was my turn to call
time to go I extended my tour there for
a year this is very briefly in the book
this book is not an autobiography it's a
memoir mainly from 64 to 73 but there
was a chapter in there about my
background and one thing that's very
relevant right now is this I went in the
Marines as a patriotic American which I
am for sure in part because I admired
and loved the fact that during Second
World War we led the world against
aggression I understood the Korean
attack to have been aggression all I
knew was was actually and I was very
proud that we were I thought it was a
right wore a limited war it's proud of
them are enrolled in that I mean I had
wasn't running yet but I became private
we're putting back aggression and what I
was due to get out of the Marines to go
to Harvard graduate school I read in the
papers that there was about to be war in
the Middle East that NASA of Egypt of
Egypt same general area were talking
about here was threatening me actually
had just nationalized the Suez Canal
that was likely to be war I did not want
my battalion in which I was not very
proud still very proud of the fact i had
been a rifle company commander as a
first lieutenant i'm very pleased by
that fact I
I'm a little embarrassed to say the one
other event I've been here I was on a
panel with jim lehrer I didn't know he
was a marine which she mentioned she was
in the Marines the same time I was and
so I saw her afterwards and he didn't
know I've been a Marine so we'd had a
lot to talk about except that I couldn't
talk and it was the late 50s when he was
in but I asked him what he done he said
he was a rifle platoon leader and I say
I'm embarrassed some cod was of say I
was a rifle company commander but the
point was I wasn't trying to trump him
it is that was probably the most
satisfying several months of my life
professional life not personally and
something I did not want my company to
be going into battle without me if they
went in sewage so I canceled my
fellowship through your fellowship at
Harvard they said I could reapply and
and extend it in the Marine Corps for a
year and I went over and in the course
of that there came a time when my ship
was ordered this is in the book briefly
ordered toward the southeast corner of
the Mediterranean and I was given my
first top secret clearance Marines don't
seek top secrets they barely see
confidential they deal with secret if
anything and they gave me a top secret
clearance for the top secret war plans
of the Sixth Fleet I was to make a
landing plan for Haifa and the Makai
next to me was making a landing plan for
our battalion for Alexandria we didn't
know which plan we would use dependent
on which the president decided who we
were fighting Israel or Egypt and we
assumed that we had to use my plan
against Israel we'd be wiped out
and if we write against Egypt we thought
very chauvinistic Lee well we'll go
through also maybe yes maybe no in the
end we evacuated about 1500 civilians
from Alexandria while it was being while
the harbor was being bombed by the
British and French I've been bombed by
the British and French and I'm not going
to make references to the present right
now you can connect the dots I'll just
tell what's in the book which was my
experience obvious some relevance to
what's happening right now over looking
at so I had been you know I don't have
never told this in public before but
since it's in the book out it's so
relevant to this week I'll tell you at
that point I was no longer company
commander I was in assistant operations
officer so I was assigned to read up on
and brief our officers as to the
background of this war that was about to
happen and so I read the anyone in the
book ship's library Britannica they had
several encyclopedias there were a
couple books on the Middle East 1 by
alpha Albert Kessler some of the kisser
I read up quite a bit of them my god
master had every right to nationalize
this canal what the British and French
are doing and we knew it was about to
happen because our cable super getting
is a corneal war against their
reinstituting their colony now at that
time I would have used the other plan
the president's it or we said so for the
president to decide right who we go to
war with but I was happy when President
Eisenhower who I had not voted for
Wren said this is aggression we won't
have it you must stop you must stop and
actually I met years later and under I
met years later the man who'd been in
charge of the planning for the British
Invasion all of us was canal and I had
an institute for strategic studies
meeting honest no big Pentagon
representing zone and I asked them in
your wildest dreams had you imagined
that you get in order to stop your
offensive in the middle of the canal and
go back because Eisenhower and said you
must stop and we will not support the
pound if you go on they pulled him back
in the middle of the operation anyway 22
of memories I have of that they're very
relevant today one is Wow Eisenhower did
it right I'm proud of my Republican
president that he put us in the position
of being against aggression even when
it's committed by our closest ally and
that was the greatest rift in the
british-american reliance perhaps ever
certainly to this day notice it isn't
happening right now that was a terrific
rift I was proud of that said that's
what I came into the Marines for and
another reason that I came into the
Marines was I grown up during the war
watching movies of London being bombed
by the nazis i thought of that is pure
Nazism the essence of Nazism bombing
civilians bombing which gets the
villians whatever was aimed at this was
aimed at civilians I didn't know what
the British were doing to the cities of
Germany I didn't know what we were doing
to the cities in Japan from then on
which was exactly the same as
not the practice we were imitating the
Nazis in response to the knots burning
them down killing as many civilians as
we possibly could I don't expect us to
do that in this war by the way and we
did not do that in Vietnam though it
could have happened the Vietnam War
could have gotten much much much worse
for the Vietnamese that I never did and
I think for ourselves so something was
learned about this direct targeting but
at the time I didn't want to be involved
in bombing civilians so I joined the
Marine Corps in part i was offered a job
in the Air Force I didn't I didn't want
to be in the Air Force so I wanted to be
with Marines who fought hand-to-hand
azimu shan ling there's some truth to
that in the Pacific one a lot of
civilians around they'll more than I
read about acting on Okinawa can you
hear me still can you hear me I don't
hear in the background while you wave
your hands if you can hear me okay I
don't wanna be told afterwards wish I
could have heard you ok so I went in the
international edition of time while we
were on that mission in wrong the week I
I met John Wayne came back I saw
pictures of what we were doing to port
say with now we the British and French I
never seen him since we were leveling
port side why do I say we look at that
in NATO I was in the Marines in contrast
to the we then we're not a little habit
you pick up in the executive branch
which I worked for for about 15 years is
you say we are you identify with it it's
us we're on the team I've got to get out
of that anyway I was glad that Americans
did not
have to see pictures like that of what
we were doing when we were doing to the
civilians of Egypt at that time I felt
sorry for the British and French who had
to look at pictures like that if they
did of what was done in the course of
their colonial aggression okay I came
back and I making this much too long
let's see / go how much time really do
we have okay I hadn't meant to go into
that but I think you'll see again I
don't have to connect the dots here how
that applies to what's coming up we're
not going to target civilians it's time
that we probably will has in the Gulf
for 11 years ago as in Serbia use
precision-guided weapons to hit
waterworks infrastructure sewage plants
and electricity now those are forbidden
targets by The Hague Convention just
like housing the effect of that I read
and these are the points that Senator
Byrd and other heroes were making less
we can argue against is the effect of
that has been according to the UN to
kill hundreds of thousands of children
in the decades after the war the decade
after the Gulf War I haven't read what's
happening in Serbia but I don't be
interesting to know when we knocked out
there he'll structure their
infrastructure that's what's lying ahead
that's why the very serious took it
anyway yep Shah was that I came back
from Vietnam rather from the marines
went to Harvard wrote a thesis on later
on uncertainty decision making under
uncertainty gambling
decisions how people make them why they
make them that's been my professional
especially actually that's another
lecture i'm giving him in november on
the keynote lecture at the Society for
the for judgment and decision theory
decision making very abstract that'll be
in November I'm not going to talk very
abstractly oh that's what my I didn't
write a book on that last year I wrote
the book 39 years ago it was published
last year it was my thesis you can get
it on Amazon on the amazon list of the
best sellers in here they rank all the
books it lists it ranks I believe
1,300,000 going up no it's hung pretty
steady there I think that garland over
priced at $65 anyway that's pretty
abstract but I won't be talking about
abstraction a month from now when I
believe will be bombing but that's just
my own bed I don't think the way and
long even if we aren't bombing yet i'll
say we're looking at a gamble now the
headlines are that many people are
making unauthorized disclosures that
they do not agree inside the government
with the estimates the president has
been presenting as flat assertions that
Saddam would use a nuclear weapon in
court if he got it and when he got it
without having been attacked and second
this is now an authorized disclosure
authorized by George Tenet head of the
CIA but let me just make a little bet to
you this letter from tenant to the
Congress was not authorized by the
president of the United States and i'll
bet that in the White House they are
furious at tenets near insubordination
to the White House by getting his actual
best
unclassified advice he Declassified it
to the Congress and what he said was
that Saddam is we think very unlikely to
give these weapons to terrorists if he
gets them biological chemical or nuclear
or to use them against us if he is not
being attacked but on the other hand if
he is attacked it is our judgment that
he has a very high likelihood of using
them I can't start troops against Israel
tenet said that what will Israel's
response be to that they've said they
would use nuclear weapons they don't say
nuclear because they have never to stay
admitted use the word nuclear directly
they said they would use everything they
have and they have no clears the man who
revealed that guy named Mordechai Vanunu
has been in prison for revealing it to
the London Times for 16 years 13 years
in total solitary for revealing to the
Israelis what everybody else in the
world know but the Israelis weren't sure
because their officials refused to
confirm it so by the way I around here a
little bit on Camilla just England when
I studied nuclear crises in the Pentagon
that was one of my jobs later and the
Pentagon I've skipped over a lot here i
actually discovered that essentially
everybody in the world know that it's
real that I looked up Suez when I had
the chance to because they'd been in it
so ignite a room like a safe a
windowless safe room in the State
Department where I was authorized to do
this research which held the eyes only
eyes only literally eyes only for the
president files of letters between
Kennedy and Khrushchev and Eisenhower
and volcanoes
like that I discovered that we in on
very Welland but by this time everybody
in the world knows except the British
the one I was on that ship in the
Mediterranean Ben Gurion of Israel the
french Foreign Minister whose name
escapes me at home and Anthony Eden in
Anthony Eden met in a chateau in France
and planned the entire invasion of the
conspiracy invasion which they were
trying to keep from eisenhower because
they knew he wouldn't like it now by
this time everybody knows that except
the British to this day and the reason
that is is because Anthony Eden simply
flatly denied it in his memoirs so they
don't know if they're like gosh they're
like everybody it's hard to believe that
your leaders flatly lie to you not hard
to believe that they mislead a little
that they don't tell you the whole truth
that they you know they fudge and they
frame it and spin it and so forth which
they do all that drug that's mostly what
they do they also why a great deal all
the time not just the president not just
Republicans or Democrats preference and
not just our leaders not just Democratic
leaders as I have strong said he summed
it all up in a way one of the major
messages of this book he summed up and
I'd heard him say this but I didn't
believe it till I been through it all
government officials lie and nothing
they say is to be believed now he
doesn't mean that they're everything
they say is a lie they tell us much
truth as well serve their purposes as
much as they can afford to it means that
anything they say maybe a lie as well as
for example a hungry one right now
Cheney says vice president is very smart
guy
said is saying day by day he believes
that our invasion of Iraq will lead to a
democratic Iraq and a democratic Middle
East having after we have been welcomed
as liberators by the people of Iraq
roses at us and so forth he paints this
in very country terms and I just read
this in time this week and that dumb the
Iraqi army he's confident will fall
apart all of it as soon as we go in and
it will liberators were liberators then
there'll be a MacArthur period sort of
as in Japan and then a democratic open
society which in turn will spread to the
new middle the rest of the Middle East
okay now that's what he says now that is
his justification and the president for
launching what everyone can see is a
preventive war by the way preemptive is
another misleading title close to allies
misuse of the term I did war planning
our planning is based on preemption of a
nuclear tech but that means if they are
on the way if their missiles have
launched if we know from electronic
intelligence or infrared or whatever
that they are about to launch or are on
the way or influence that lets get that
we don't wait for the warheads to arrive
you may believe and you may have been
told certain many times that we wait and
take the second blow and will never go
over there and do it first but that's
not that's not our planning we will all
our plans are based on going first going
second first as they say on pre-empting
that attack that's what pre-empting
means it's a technical term what he's
talking about what she's using the word
preemptive for has nothing to do with
preemption no attack is on the way
nothing is imminent
it's a war that is not in the context of
an imminent or ongoing attack it's a
preventive war and that's the best term
you can put forward another term is what
the British and French were doing in
Suez aggression that's what Eisenhower
called a pen and he was right it's what
the whole world called what Saddam did
11 years ago he said he was liberating a
real province of Iraq and so forth I
don't know if any of his people believe
that but his soldiers didn't want to
either to fight for that but it was
aggression and on the basis of that word
I'm giving a talk about Iraq I'll try to
stop that's not in the book obviously
but I can tie it up with the book
quickly
on the basis of that not just a word
with the reality that Saddam was
violating a central principle of
furnished order for the last several
hundred years the one thing everybody
agrees on what is aggression very hard
to get agreement on that usually but
once in a while you don't you get
consensus that's aggression um someone
sonam did that all his allies just about
supported us we use their bases they try
and animated everything and they weren't
all that great friends of us either at
that point but aggression that has to be
stopped well they ain't going to do that
to us or the United States they're not
gonna ice except but the fact is a lot
of people in the in the government right
now I can feel confident from my
experience in like I jumped around here
I was saying a moment ago that Cheney
was saying things I read him last night
and I wrote in the margin can Richard
Cheney possibly believe this you know
the roses at us the democracy there
aren't going to be any democracy will
not allow democracy in the Middle East
but that's in a right in part because it
would split up Iraq and we don't want
that we've supported a sunny
dictatorship Sunni Muslim forever
essentially which is a minority about
fourteen percent of the area of the
Iraqis are sunny sixty-four percent are
Shiite like Iran what's the chance we're
going to allow one man one woman one
vote to the Shiites in Iraq to join Iran
the street no chance so democracy is not
in their future okay there's no more
chance than we were about to allow as I
realized when the
when I read the Pentagon Papers what I
learned having by this time I didn't
even mention this but been to Vietnam
for two years witnessed combat as a
civilian participated I was shot at I
even shot back because I was a former
marine company commander so I used that
background which was described at length
no animal in Vietnam I used that to
observe places where people who didn't
have that background couldn't observe I
saw things that civilians didn't
ordinarily see on a lighter note shany
didn't see them he was draft age during
Vietnam but he spent the war in a secure
location in in Wyoming in Wyoming he
missed his chance unlike Powell the one
man in the administration did see
Vietnam and who by all accounts is
digging his heels in against this war
like every military man we've heard from
every military all the ones who worked
for Bush Senior for Clinton for Reagan
everyone only civilians we've heard of
who are not in Vietnam though they were
all draft age are pushing this war and
saying it's going to be a cakewalk which
Norman Schwarzkopf says it is not going
to be a cakewalk ok what's I wish this
book actually it's they say it's timely
actually it's a good month or two over
do i wish i'm still timely it's going to
be timely for quite a while our
conflicts in the Middle East are not
going to be alluring two weeks or three
weeks even if Saddam is found and
assassinated etc as I say Saddam is no
more representative himself than a
Shiite
of Iraq no more representative than the
man we made dictator of Vietnam for many
years young who was a Catholic I never
noticed in Vietnam the funny thing about
that country of Buddhists entirely been
run by a Catholic or what that said
about our relation to Vietnam I really
never thought of that till I read the
history and the Pentagon Papers it might
have been more obvious if he'd been
Jewish for example I might have seen
more they didn't vote this man in it was
a little worse than Jewish because the
Catholics were the ones who would
collaborate with the French they've been
converted by the French and they've been
given high jobs by the friendship so
forth so a Catholic president was not a
logical by the way our president to the
general to was also a Catholic he'd
converted saw the light so our man in
Iraq is not going to be broadly
representative he ain't going to be
occurred let me tell you that for
example so i read in the pentagon papers
in 69 by which time i had already been
thinking we should get out of Vietnam
for reasons that are in the book but
I've used up my time here is old we
should get out of Vietnam what I read
was something that I think some people
on the Pentagon probably perceived today
about this situation because it's
different this is much more open
aggression than Vietnam era was after it
studied history that's in the Pentagon
Papers what I didn't know in the
Pentagon was we've been backing a
colonial water there from the beginning
that it was not a legitimate worthwhile
to was the cause that went wrong as I
believe I can't colonial war paying
eighty percent of the cost of it for
nine years that's what i read this is
where I'd been shot at him and that I
shot back although I'm glad to say I'm
not aware of having hit anybody that's
not a joke on testing County targets
dinner the war had been wrong from the
start we had no more right to win in
Vietnam I conclude and if that puts you
off and read the book and see if it
still puts you off I'd like this to be
read by a lot of people who still
support that war I hope in will be and I
know it has been to some degree it's the
military people I know I'd like it to be
read by a lot of Vietnam veterans who
want to understand how this could have
happened how could they have done it
that's what people will be asking I
believe however this comes out in the
next little while in Iraq how could they
have done it well this book is in a
birthday this book is about we about my
colleagues and me how could I have done
it I can see I didn't know the history
within I explained that I didn't look it
up I didn't know that well I was 30
years old at the start when I first went
to Vietnam just out of the reins and so
forth but um how could how could this
have happened well at any rate what I
read was that there was we had no right
to win in Vietnam from the beginning any
more than we had any more hope many more
than the French and no more prospect of
winning than the French that's very
different in Iraq itself will win Iraq
that's the different kind of war well we
win the resistance that may follow it
how will pacification look in Vietnam
after we have Baghdad whether we did it
surgically or we did it brutally as in
port side and level it one way or
another we'll have Baghdad Saddam will
not be rolling I hear from now
well the fighting me over in Iraq will
be over elsewhere will it be over in
Afghanistan later on we don't know I
don't know you don't know when the
president doesn't know there's no way to
know that's the gamble that Congress
just signed on to very irresponsibly
except for 133 old courageous Pedro led
by barbara Lee a year ago and some
Republicans and 23 senators 21
Republicans at 21 Democrats one
Republican one independent Jeffords
still looking very good Jeffords by the
way senator byrd looking very good bird
said in his speech he is one of two
people in the Senate who were a present
to vote on the first talking Gulf
Resolution when I was in the Pentagon he
said I am ashamed of that decision I
regret it intensely I wish that I had
been the third person along with Mars
and groaning to vote against it Ted
Kennedy younger at the time also voted
against this at this point very much to
the correct my problem was what do I do
when I perceive from this history what
is not easy to perceive in that case
this is an aggressive war it's a
wrongful war how far should I go well I
won't recapitulate the book i will say
that i had the look to meet at that time
Americans young Americans who are doing
everything they could and that meant
since these were some of them were male
and draft age like all the others were
running the government now that there
are they would refuse to go to it openly
make a statement of their resistance to
what they thought was a wrongful war do
it non-violently intrusive
like Gandhi like Martin Luther King like
the row expect a night in jail
protesting what he called and what u.s.
grant agreed with and what Lincoln
agreed with was an american war of
aggression against mexico and that's why
throw standeth night in jail so roasted
at that time in assessing on civil
disobedience cast your whole vote not a
strip of paper merely but your whole
influence well a lot of people in
congress last week cast their vote wong
some of them catch the right on their
conscience when they tell you why they
voted yes should you believe that any
more than executive officials to
congressman tell you the truth about why
they do things more than executives no
no no how do you know that well you make
a judgment when bird say you know off
all the circumstances I believe bird he
is telling the truth when he gives his
reasons for voting no maybe there's
other reasons as well but as far as he
goes it's gone for the others as well
barbara Lee its theorem the ones who
said yes hard to believe that they
believed some of this stuff any more
than shame but who am i pointing at I'm
calling this book of how I did not leave
the government I did not tell what I
know at the time when I could have
senator Morris told me in 1971 after the
Pentagon Papers came out this 7,000 page
top secret history quote of us decision
making in Vietnam from nineteen forty
five to nineteen sixty eight that's the
title of the Pentagon Papers 7,000 pages
all top secret I copied it at the RAND
Corporation in nineteen sixty-nine after
at a time when I believe Nixon was about
to escalate again this is the heart of
the book and I gave it to Senator
Fulbright of the Foreign Relations
Committee he promised hearings or he
said he hoped to hold hearing so that he
did not to invasions later I gave it to
the New York Times to the Washington
they were enjoined and to the Washington
Post they were enjoined than to Indian
17 other newspapers forward joined
altogether subject of a big manhunt
while I was putting this out that's all
in the book of Supreme Court avoiding
the injunctions but I was put on trial
eventually facing 115 years in prison as
the book tells that didn't seem to have
had any could affect the war went on but
for reasons we wish I had time to go
into it not amazingly enough he turned
out that there was an effect because
Nixon was so afraid that I might have
other revelations about him and I did
but I didn't have documents that he had
to take criminal measures to shut me up
the point is that having read Thoreau
and Martin Luther King and read about
Rosa Parks and then meeting people who
are living that life on their way to
prison is what made me realize I should
do what I can this is only history but
it's all I've got I'll put that home I
wish I had documents on what's now
happening if I'd had I wouldn't have put
out the Pentagon Papers I would have put
those out the way some people are very
creditably doing now putting out
information in even documents on current
planning to show us that this isn't just
about a rockets the whole Middle East
this is not just a dia parade this is a
it's going to eventually involve scores
the thousands of people and so forth all
this stuff the Rumsfeld is complaining
about they are putting it on i'm very
happy that's the major impact i would
want this book to have would be on
people to say consider in the government
if you believe your president is now
lying the country into what you see as a
wrongful war that will cost many lives
on both sides then you should consider
doing what i wish i had done in 1964 and
1965 don't do what I did as in this book
don't wait till the bombs are falling
don't wait till it's one more after
another Syria Iraq Iran Saudi Arabia put
it on now and whatever cost to yourself
could be worth going to jail for ten
years hundred years to 115 years oh of
course if you're if you're able to
contemplate that I don't tell anybody do
that they have families their job they
have a their own calculation their own
sense of what will help and what they
could do otherwise paul hasn't quit and
I think I know why for the same reason
McNamara didn't in 66 he believes Arthas
is my own guess he believes that if he
left it would go worse and he could well
be right so he has a very hard choice to
me the people who don't have to tell
themselves my god maybe I can really
make a difference inside should be
thinking of what they can do outside
John I'm trying to say that some people
are doing it so we have finally I'll end
up with the fact with a couple two
quotes here the reason they went after
me is HR Haldeman this is on tape now
these are unauthorized disclosures that
the president a president taped
everybody as you know tapes got out his
didn't plan on that so just the day
after the Pentagon Papers came out HR
Haldeman was saying to the president in
the white in the oval office now on tape
along this stuff has never come out this
particular one came out in April of this
last year is that almost 30 years later
31 years learn about the Pentagon Papers
if Don was saying this morning to the
ordinary guy all this is a bunch of
gobbledygook but out of the gobbledygook
comes a very clear thing you can't trust
the government you can't believe what
they say and you can't rely on their
judgment in the implicit for
infallibility of presidents which has
been an accepted thing in America is
badly hurt by this because it shows that
people do things the president wants to
do even though it's wrong and the
president can be wrong that was the
message I wanted to get out nadaan he
was quoting was Donald Rumsfeld who was
working for Nixon at that time as a
White House aide and he got the picture
he got the method and it's true but
telling the truth can have an effect my
book ends with this
less paid last thing it ends for my
trial ended Congress because of the
revelations of the criminal actions the
president had done to stop me from
telling more truths to stop me because I
was doing what Scott Ritter has been
doing for several months I was doing
everything I could that's what Scott
Ritter is doing and he's my latest hero
i just sent this book damn if you know
who I mean you know who's covered her
he's doing everything he can and Senator
Byrd cast his whole vote and barbara Lee
and some others and that's what's needed
can that do any good well it didn't stop
the resolution and friendly it's not
going to stop this war and this war will
not be averted I think by anything but
it won't be stopped as a series of wars
without a lot more courage and sacrifice
than we've seen so far from most of the
Democrats or others but Kennard Hill
well came out the president had done a
lot of crimes because I was on trial
they finally came out in my courtroom
and Congress under the pressure of that
for the first time the week my trial
ended stays before voted to cut off
money for the war which then went
through a little process but it ended in
august this was May eleventh day my
trial learned in this the end of the
book here's our Oval Office tape which I
read after they was released this April
presidents saying to Haldeman the same
time at eleven o'clock that Judge burn
in my courtroom was dismissing all
charges against me and Tony Rizzo on the
grounds of Governor
misconduct which was very nice actually
Mitchell was indicted my attorney
general then was indicted the same
morning and so that was fine but the
more important thing was Congress had
voted for the first time to come off the
money so the president now says to hold
him for example on this I've heard this
I can imitate too well with one voice
now for example on this national
security thing we have the rocky
situation where the son of a bitching
thief is made a national hero and it's
going to get off on a mistrial and the
New York Times gets a Pulitzer Prize for
stealing documents they're trying to get
at us with thieves what in the name of
God if we come to it some satisfaction
reading it and the the end of the book
is what we had come back to was a
Democratic Republic not an elected
monarchy a government under law with
Congress the courts in the press
functioning to curtail executive abuses
as our Constitution envisioned and a
senator byrd laid out for is no more
over for the first time and this or any
other country that the legislature was
casting its whole vote against an
ongoing presidential war it was
reclaiming through its power of the
purse the war power it had feckless lee
delegated nine years earlier Congress
was stopping the bombing and the war was
going to end
downstairs
Daniel Ellsberg's book secrets a memoir
of Vietnam and the Pentagon Papers is
published by viking press you can visit
them online at penguin putnam calm